Peter King who's back here on the show
how are you pk Rich Eisen I'm doing well
thank you appreciated and thanks for
having me on to talk about the book yeah
we will definitely talk about that I do
want to hit some topics du jour if you
don't mind here in the Honda inside a
report with Peter King on the Rich Eisen
show so what do you think of Stanford's
contract what do you think of it it was
you know the game of quarterback
contracts is very very simple it's a
game of hopscotch and I talked to Derek
Carr about three weeks ago in Napa at
Raiders camp and he basically shrugged
his shoulders and he said Matthew
Stafford is gonna pass this any day it's
really not a big deal it's the same
thing that Joe Flacco's said two years
ago said all these guys know it somebody
sets the boundaries and you know
somebody else jumps over the boundary
and it'll be the same thing with Kirk
Cousins if he ever gets a long-term deal
and everybody else say oh my god you
can't take her cousin's 27 million a
year you can't think of it in terms of
the monopoly money that they're throwing
around because very simply if the salary
cap goes up every single year seven or
eight or nine percent which it does if
it's going to do that then you know the
money is twenty million two years ago
should be twenty four million today it
just should be because in today's
dollars that's what it's worried you're
paying a quarterback the same percentage
of the salary cap that you're probably
paid on 15 years ago it's no different
well do you think we'll we'll see a
point in time Peter we're a team like
the Lions with a quarterback with the
numbers like Stafford has racked up in
terms of yards and also career playoff
wins at age 29 would would rather do you
think we would see a team that they
would rather trade that guy away let him
walk and start over again and that is
the way that they will conduct business
in the NFL and come up with some sort of
failure
if you all laugh at them I mean that's
that's a stupid way to do business
would you rather not pay somebody who's
the most important person near franchise
including the owner that the the general
manager and the coach he's the most
important person in your franchise your
starting quarterback and you would
rather say Oh we'll go is Colt McCoy
then or whatever your back shore is you
know I mean it's that's a silly way to
do business if somebody does that I mean
they're gonna go five and eleven or they
could come up with some sort of
Moneyball formula where they could
figure out other players on the team and
the quarterback becomes somewhat of a
fungible part and then you pay everybody
else to try and win football games and
you don't get stuck in a situation the
problem with the problem with that logic
is that if you are a starting
quarterback on a team that wins twelve
games you're not going to pay the
starting quarterback thirteen million
dollars a year or some or eleven million
that's faulty logic no agent for a
quarterback like that I mean the only
quarterback in you know in this era who
consistently takes less than what he
would be worth on the open market and
doesn't I'm doing so is Tom Brady he's
done it since 2004 when he said to the
Patriots look you just pay me a
respectable number and if you guarantee
me that you're going to spend to the
salary cap I'm fine with that because
Brady knew that he would rather have
good players surrounding him because he
always knew that he could make a huge
amount of money off the field very
easily and that to me is a smart way to
do it but but I don't think anybody any
quarterback would say for instance if he
was a quote complimentary piece
end quote he wouldn't just say okay well
you can pay me you know forty percent of
what the going rate is for a great
quarterback when we win twelve games
that's not the way quarterbacks are
gonna work Peter King here in the Honda
insider report on the Rich Eisen show
ask him the poll question Chris Brocklin
go for it the poll question of the day
here ask him yeah Peter who would you
want is your team's quarterback for the
next five seasons Matt Stafford Derek
Carr
cousin's Andrew Luck drew brees all five
of them of the top five annually paid
quarterbacks right now I would take car
right now but three months from now I
might take I might take luck because you
know right now Andrew looks shoulder
worries me I think it's going to be fine
long term but right now it worries me
I'm smitten by the potential of Derek
Carr but quite honestly any of those
guys I'd be happy with I'd be very happy
with Matthew Stafford even though he
hasn't won a playoff game so what is
what what what is the deal with Luck's
shoulder right now Peter I mean and it
the way it was explained to me very
simply and Andrew Luck was absolutely
fine with this is that look we are not
going to let this guy go on the field
for us until our doctors tell us that
his shoulder is absolutely fine if if it
takes two or three weeks of a regular
season so be it this is about the next
10 years it's not about the next 10
games so you know to me this is a
different situation than like Drew Brees
in 2006 maybe even a different situation
Cam Newton I saw Cam Newton last
Thursday in Jacksonville he threw two
passes that each went three yards beyond
the line of scrimmage we learned
absolutely nothing about Cam Newton in
the in the health of his shoulder in
that game and and so the Indianapolis
Colts have basically said look when the
doctors tell us that Andrew Luck can rip
the ball you know absolutely normally
you know 25 yards down the field or
throw a bomb you know 45 yards up the
seam with no pain and everything is fine
in his shoulder then he's playing until
then he's not and now with Vontae Davis
out for multiple games as as Chuck
Pagano said today because he hurt
himself in a preseason weekend that also
saw Julian Edelman go down and Spencer
wear go down and a handful of other
players have gone down I've said this
week that if I owned an NFL team I tell
my coach look you get to choose
everything that happens on a Thursday
Sunday Monday Saturday during the sea
and but I'm in charge during the
preseason and no starters play and I
don't care what you say and and and then
I would tell the league let everyone in
for free and do whatever you want to do
with preseason games what's the fix here
Peter the fix is in my opinion that I
think players look I was at the
Pittsburgh Steelers camp and wrote about
this with Mike Tomlin basically saying
that I you have to let players hit each
other and be physical during the summer
because we you know it would be like
sending a boxer into the ring you know
for a prizefight having not sparred at
all leading up to the fight and I get
that and I think there's got to be some
happy medium here I really do rich
it's that any look at Mike Tomlin's
record and you look at Pete Carroll's
record to me traditionally over the last
three four or five years those are the
two coaches in the NFL who are the most
physical during training camp okay and
you combine those two guys in their time
in the NFL the ones 65% of their games
are 63 percent so what are you saying
that you know you want to do what all
the people do who don't win games and
again look I'm not saying this is a
one-size-fits-all solution in any way
shape or form I'm saying that I think
the easy way to do it is to say nobody
is tackling anybody nobody is hitting
anybody in training camp my players are
not playing until after Labor Day but I
don't know that that's the solution
either I really don't I I think I think
every team should make that decision but
I don't I would not do what you're
suggesting to do if I was an owner okay
last question for you before we get to
your book get to the the book you've
edited about dr. Z I can understand Tom
Paula Sarah my colleague at the NFL
Network saying Matt Forte is on the
market right now III that one I get with
the Jets because the the cause is lost
why would the Browns want to want to try
and trade Joe Hayden as I'm seeing today
on the outset of a season where they're
starting a rookie quarterback and
the salary caps already is what it is
well and if that is the case and I don't
know that it is I I saw the same thing
that you saw but I don't know that is
but if that's the case then it's clearly
the brown saying that you know were not
convinced that Joe Hayden is going to be
a shutdown cornerback
the Browns already have eight picks in
the first four rounds next year they
don't have to get more and I think at
some point all of these draft picks
become almost a self-defeating prophecy
you know you yeah really in my opinion
it's why when I was at their camp I was
talking to some of the people you know
some of their management people and I
said you guys gotta stop trading people
man I mean you know yeah and you can't
trade go thomas i don't care if he's
only got three years left or whatever he
has left I mean this is it it gets to be
ridiculous after a while and you know
they drafted 98 guys last year including
about 16 receivers and let Taylor
Gabriel go I mean it's just it's stupid
it's just stupid I'm not and I'm not
saying they're running as they're doing
a stupid I'm saying cutting Taylor
Gabriel was done letting terrelle pryor
go in my opinion was dumb and they think
Kenny Britt is every bit as good as
terrelle pryor I don't and you know
we'll see what we'll see who ends up
being right so let's talk about the book
here for the younger generation who's
whose doctors they let him know you know
Paul Zimmerman is a guy who is a totally
unique person in our business suffered
no fools he was one of these guys who
and and is one of these guys he's still
with us but he is one of these guys who
more than anybody that I've ever met in
the business is you know a 1950 sports
writer come to life he was a skeptic he
was kind of an acerbic often bitter guy
mad at the world but he questioned
everything and as close as I was to him
he could drive me out of my mind I mean
there was a time when I had to present
Paul Tagliabue to the Hall of Fame in
front of all of Fame
committee in 2008 and I presented my
case and he got up and he totally ripped
my case to shreds and I was so angry at
him I wanted to punch him in the nose
but it's one of those things about him
that I truly respected he didn't care
that we were friends or he didn't care
anything about that he was going to say
exactly what he thought this a guy who
you know interviewed Lombardi and had a
closeness with Lombardi he drank wine
with Chuck Noll who nobody knew he
sparred with Ernest Hemingway in his
younger days I mean you know he's just
he's a unique character in the history
of the media and this book has so many
fun stories you know today even the
private guys relatively private like Tom
Brady I mean shoot I did a 76 minute
podcast or than a week after the Super
Bowl
there's it you know so nobody today is
really going to be unknown and yet all
the great mythical great players you
know starting in about 1955 there's like
a 20 year period where Paul Zimmerman
knew him better than anybody so I think
this book will help you realize how Joe
Namath got to be so famous how Johnny
Unitas got famous Vince Lombardi Jim
Brown just a lot of fun things in this
book dr. Z The Lost memoirs of an
irreverent football writer before I let
you go Peter just Jerry Kramer get in
finally what do you think I think he
probably does rich but you know I don't
know you know he needs 39 votes out of
48 that's and then you know a lot of
people say well he ought to be able to
get that well you think that about a lot
of people going into that meeting but
we'll see about the discussion I
understand the the emotion about Jerry
Kramer no question about it but you know
he's been up for he's been a finalist
ten times on Ballou nine times by a jury
of his peers people who watched him all
the time and nine times the people who
watched him every week didn't vote him
in so what's the deal and one time when
he was a senior's candidate in 1997 he
didn't get the 80% of the votes so I you
know we'll see what happens but I don't
think it's
don't think it's slam-dunk but but you
know we'll see what happened Peter
always loved chat with you if I don't
chat with you before the season and joy
kick off and then we'll have you back on
as soon as possible thanks thank you so
much Rick always it's Peter King @s i
underscore Peter Cronk the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that download around please
just if if it's a memory thing just
delete other refs you don't need those
apps this app the Rich Eisen show up you
need that